After updating the rules for sagas with
the release of Final Fantasy last year,
Wizards have updated sagas again. And
while I think this change is a buff to
most sagas, it's certainly a small nerf
to Urza's Saga and a handful of other
sagas, too.
Let me explain. So, what has actually
changed? Effectively, instead of a
written rule giving a saga its first
lore counter, it's now an inherent
ability.
Now, what do I mean by that?
Previously, if you had a Doubling Season
in play, which says, "If an effect would
put one or more counters on a permanent
you control, it puts twice that many of
those counters on that permanent
instead."
And then you play a saga,
the saga would enter with one counter.
Compare that to playing a planeswalker,
for example, Jace, Unraveler of Secrets,
which would enter with 10 loyalty
counters.
So, why would the counters double for a
planeswalker and not the saga?
This is due to the fact that the rules
for sagas getting counters when they
enter was just that,
a rule.
Whereas the rules for planeswalkers
getting loyalty counters when they enter
explicitly gave the planeswalker an
intrinsic ability.
The ability would create a replacement
effect, and it's this replacement effect
that Doubling Season could interact
with.
"If an effect would put one or more
counters on a permanent you control, it
puts twice that many of those counters
on that permanent instead."
For clarity's sake, let's compare the
rules. For planeswalkers, we have rule
306.5b,
which says, "A planeswalker has the
intrinsic ability. This permanent enters
with a number of loyalty counters on it
equal to its printed loyalty number.
This ability creates a replacement
effect."
Versus the Saga old rule 714.3a,
as a Saga without the read ahead ability
enters the battlefield, its controller
puts a lore counter on it.
Again,
this rule for Sagas didn't create any
effects that Doubling Season could
interact with.
Now, here's the new rule for Sagas.
Rule 714.3a,
each Saga without read ahead has the
intrinsic ability this Saga enters with
a lore counter on it. This ability
creates a replacement effect.
As you can see, the Sagas now have an
intrinsic ability or a replacement
effect.
This is the same for Sagas with read
ahead.
Rule 714.3b
says, each Saga with read ahead has the
intrinsic abilities as the Saga enters,
choose a number between one and this
Saga's final chapter number.
And this Saga enters with the chosen
number of lore counters on it.
These abilities create replacement
effects.
Now, this does have some other side
effects we need to consider.
Let's say there's a Blood Moon in play.
Previously, when we played as a Saga,
the Saga would enter with a counter and
none of its abilities would trigger
because it was just a mountain.
If Blood Moon was then removed at the
beginning of your next main phase, the
Saga would trigger and you'd get the
second counter.
With the new rules, now the Saga would
enter with no counters at all.
This is because of how replacement
effects work.
Similar to how if you play a shock land
with Blood Moon in play, it would always
enter untapped and you don't have the
choice to pay two life.
Similarly, if you played one of the
Final Fantasy creature summons with a
Humility in play, it would enter with no
counters.
Again, if the Humility was removed, you
would have to wait until your next first
main phase for it to get a counter.
The comparison here would be Meddling
Mage and Humility.
With the Humility in play, you wouldn't
get a chance to name anything with their
replacement effect. As I mentioned
before, Sagas didn't interact with
Doubling Season, and this was perfect
for the Sagas with Read Ahead.
However, with the new rules changes, if
you decided to Read Ahead while there is
a Doubling Season in play,
with the current Read Ahead Sagas, the
Saga is immediately going to end because
if you pick anything more than the first
chapter, the Saga will enter with double
the amount of lore counters, thanks to
Doubling Season, and all the chapters
will instantly trigger.
It's worth pointing out that for Sagas
and Doubling Season effects, when the
Saga enters with two or more lore
counters, it will trigger that many
chapter abilities.
And because they all trigger at the same
time, you can stack the triggers in
whichever order you want.
That's about everything you need to know
for this rules change. What do you
think?
As always, be sure to like the video if
you learned something, and subscribe cuz
if you don't, my next video won't come
out until next year.
Thanks for watching, and I'll see you in
the next one.